if our nation can be said to have a soul
her majesty for 70 years has been its
guardian angel
i'm trevor phillips i was born at the
dawn of the second elizabethan age
all these children would have grown up
with rationing
i've been rediscovering how we lived
sometimes they weren't enough coal to
make a fire so we have to just sit there
and shiver
and a little of how we loved
i went to get up and he went aren't you
gonna give me a kiss then i went what
after you've had shellfish
i've been looking back at the good times
we all have proper pop out of fizzy
bottles which was possible
and the not so good times
i'd get pulled up two three times a
month and what's really sad about it
i thought it was normal
yet through it all one royal constant
at the same time a steadfast rock of
stability and a mirror of great change
in us
[Music]
queen elizabeth ii passes from the abbey
consecrated and dedicated to her life
work by the solemn and hallowed ritual
of coronation
a mantle almost a thousand years old is
laid on the shoulders of a new
generation
[Music]
the young queen will come to reign over
the largest empire the world had ever
seen
after a bitter war she had to symbolize
both a past and a future of prosperity
and peace
[Music]
and so
this day of days most memorable comes to
an end
and with it begins a new era the new
elizabethan h
long may she reign
[Applause]
in 1953
few would have pictured britain as it is
now
dear jamaica right
after a decade of austerity my mother
agonized about how she'd tell my father
that they were about to have another
hungry mouth to feed
i'm going to try them and see what
they're like
in the three score in 10 years since i
was born that young woman grew in
stature to become revered even perhaps
loved by her nation
of course she changed as did we her
people
but like her majesty
whilst many things about us may have
looked different
an awful lot has remained the same
to try to disentangle the old from the
new i've been chatting to pals in
london's brixton for many emblematic of
how far we've come from the days when
the empire meant exotic lands across the
sea
and i've been making some new friends in
berries and edmonds whose church spires
and niche municipal gardens recall a
britain that some thought was already
disappearing 70 years ago
but our journey starts in the former
manufacturing powerhouse of lancashire
where the paradox of continuity and
change is at its plainest so much
different yet so much the same
we've got a box of photographs of
coronation day on the 2nd june 1953.
we've got
a parade here
so we've got um the young page boy
carrying the crown and then here comes
the queen
background
but it's kind of a classic northern
scene isn't it you've got the cobbled
streets the terrace terrace housing
and here's and here's the the coronation
of the of the queen
that's great she's sitting there on her
little throne and
what do you think that
the queen would mean to a street like
this i think there's genuine enthusiasm
or strong feeling for this young queen
but i think it was also about marking
the end of something and a new
beginning
things are generally looking better
wages are higher there's full employment
there's a security of the nhs and the
welfare state they're not only marking
the coronation of the queen
the marking the beginnings of change
not just in their time but across the
country
if you wanted a job there was always one
available
bolton stood at the heart of a global
industry that would fuel the new
elizabethan age
into the busy dark end of liverpool and
manchester come cargos of raw cotton
from the far corners of the world
bolton's merchants grew rich turning the
empire's raw materials into cloth for
the growing population
[Music]
for two decades much of the country
shared its prosperity
of course it wasn't shared by everyone
most people went on the bus of course
because nobody had any cars
i'd get on the bus on saturday morning
get off in town and walk through town to
the mercuto
and
we could buy
broken biscuits and for so much say
sixpence something like that
that were all we could afford
bolton's women could only dream of
buying the dresses made from the cloth
they wove but all the same they paid a
high price when i left school i worked
in mill
for two pounds ten a week
sweat and slave from mine till night to
keep me bobbing straight
i changed them with a gadget in case my
hands got burned
never stopping never stopping day and
night their turn
i pieced a thousand knots a week
to keep the yarn flowing
and at the end of every day tired feet
were homer going
i wrote that a long time ago
i started work when i was 15 in the
middle
and we had a long way to walk
from where i lived
we started it up past seven in the
morning and we had to be there on time
or we got
our pair cut
and the pair wasn't
much as it was it was only two pound
ten shillings
a week two shillings a week
and i had to give two pounds of that to
my mother and keep two shillings
so i could go out once a week that's all
it was so noisy
and very very busy the machines are
going all the time that's why i'm a bit
deaf i think
but you had to go whether you wanted or
not because it'd be a wage
but there was plenty of money in the
town enough to erect and maintain public
buildings that rivaled anything down
south
bolton exuded self-confidence and civic
pride
bolton's art gallery opened in 1947.
henry moore's sculptures were purchased
at that period of the 50s he was like
the big public figure in british arts
barber head with sculptures were
purchased and then works by the younger
generation like elizabeth frink uh lynn
chadwick robert clattworthy
so there's this decision i think that
bolton
would have this great collection of
contemporary art and would be a beacon
of culture
across the northwest
what do you think that tells us about if
you like the mood of bolton and its own
self-image at the time i think it shows
great confidence in the town that still
this was a a textile town there was this
sense that
bolton was a powerful industrial town
and that the people of bolton should
accept have access to the greatest art
being made at that time but the town had
its own artists their canvas was made of
grass their frame the football field and
their gainsborough the great nat loft
house
in coronation year lofthouse took the
wanderers to wembley to play in the fa
cup final and as ever what mattered to
the nation was signaled by a royal
presence the duke of edinburgh meets the
boys from blackpool at wembley before
their cup final battle with bolton
wanderers from the royal box her majesty
the queen watches the duke shake hands
with the white shirted wanderers who are
making their fourth appearance at
wembley oh we've had some great players
in the 50s
when i arrived eventually
a lot of the players were still talking
about that team
it would be as big as like man city it
may maybe at that time even man united i
mean
its supporters would be
turning out in the thousands and
thousands and thousands
[Applause]
now bolton get going smoothly castle
collects and passes the ball goes to
that loft house he shoots farm fumbles
and it's a goal
bolton have drawn first blood within 90
seconds
right from the opening whistle it looked
as though it was going to be bolton's
day
but in the dying seconds the cup was
snatched from their graspers
[Applause]
[Music]
bolton 3.
[Music]
[Applause]
here come the winners gallant blackpool
who turned what seemed defeat into one
of the most dramatic victories ever seen
at wembley
although bolton gone to win the fa cup
later that decade the stumble at wembley
was perhaps an omen of what was to come
within a generation the bustling town
would suffer a dramatic reversal of
fortune
one of the key trends in post-war
british history is de-industrialization
the decline of the manufacturing
industries shifting occupations i've
been
looking at the kind of jobs that people
do now compared to the jobs that they
were doing in 1952 1953 there's an
extraordinary difference
and you know and that's changed
communities
it's changed places like bolton
so we were straight onto the front
street terrace and our house was
actually collapsing so it was showered
up with big pieces of wood and it was
collapsing into the old railway line
when it rained we took the curtains in
at the bottom because the rain came in
through the windows
so when you look at 1984
1990 even and a lot of people still
living like they were living in the
1950s shows the impact of how wages jobs
and the economic change was still
affecting people 30 years after the
mills started to close
[Music]
berries and edmonds in the heart of east
anglia for many the very picture of
traditional england
this ancient market town with its
medieval churches and ruined abbeys
has been part of the royal story for
more than a thousand years
so this is liberty silks on linen
and it depicts the death of saint edmund
not very nice is it
definitely not it wouldn't want me
happen to you or me
the death of edmund is commemorated in
legend he was shot full of arrows after
being captured after losing a battle at
thetford he was tied to a tree
refused to renounce his christian faith
and then for good measure okay cut his
head off
he was buried at hoxen and it became a
place of pilgrimage and so much so they
moved him to the abbey here in berlin
edmonds and became one of the biggest
abbeys in christendom
this town's story about itself
is inseparable from the story of the
sovereign
when the
abbey itself was in existence we had a
lot of kings and queens
come to bearish lebanese to pay homage
to edmund at the shrine
from um edward the first right the way
through to
obviously today
with the
queen elizabeth we all we all love the
queen i think if you've served you
you've seen her you've appreciated her
you've seen what service she's given to
our nation
she came here for the maundy service
and she walked past us and handed out
mandy money
and everyone was so proud that day the
streets were lined with people and they
all had special poses of flowers the
history and the legacy i think we all
like as well
all that goes into all these different
services
april the annual st george's day parade
brownies cubs scouts guides on parade as
they have been for a hundred years the
day is supposed to be a homage to saint
george but when these young people
pledge their allegiance there's just one
person who can claim their loyalty
and they really think of her as one of
them tell me about what you
guys have been doing today and what it's
what it's about about what does it mean
i think representing the girls and the
girl guiding movement and we're really
honored to have had the queen as a
brownie a guide and then a ranger
herself so it's about showing our voices
and our representation i think she's an
icon for the british
the british identity and i think it's
about women being able to be icons for
themselves and for the communities that
they live in and grow in and work in
[Music]
what i love about this is that this is
the kind of england that my parents
would have recognized when they arrived
here seven decades ago just before the
start of the elizabethan reign
the symbols that we're seeing here the
music the bands the flags were the same
symbols that were used all over the
empire
[Music]
[Music]
this film taken on coronation day in
1953 bears a remarkable resemblance to
the event today
the parade musters in the same place
before marching through the town on the
same route
[Music]
there were street parties going on i i
know that at the
top of the estate there was a street
party carried out just outside the large
public house that used to be there
and i remember running after in a race
an orange that was bowled across the
road
and for that i got a queen's coronation
book
so that would have been your prize for
winning the race which i've still got
somewhere
at home
but not everything remains the same at
the time of the coronation berry relied
on its fertile land to make a living
farming in east india is a highly
mechanized industry and by far the most
important source of live level
like the cotton mills of bolton
mechanization was transforming an entire
industry
but for the workers who remained as in
the mills the hours were long the wages
meager and the future uncertain
[Music]
i mean agricultural work is low paid
you know and agriculture is changing in
the post-war period partly this is
coming out of transformations to given
the reliance
of the nation on agriculture during the
war but there's you know mechanisation
and efficiency going on so
you know jobs in agriculture decline
very steeply
a great deal of the sugar used in the
british isles comes from east anglia
my father for most of his working life
he worked at the british sugar factory
for the manufacture and crushing of the
sugar beet
having food on the table was very
important but there wasn't any luxuries
as such
people who grew up in the early 20th
century they'd never had the facilities
they'd never had proper bathrooms they
never had toilet facilities you know
visiting the um
privy at the bottom of the garden you
know that sort of thing but certainly
after the second world war and with
rationing ending
people then started realizing there was
more to life they could enjoy
after feeding the nation the new reigns
first priority was obvious homes
the young queen and her dashing husband
a war veteran had their pick of palaces
but for their contemporaries new homes
had to be found in new places
britain was on the move
[Music]
it's fantastic to get a place well i
mean we never dreamed of getting our own
house to be in london
i don't know what we would have done if
i had to come down here i don't know
where i would have gone or what where my
life would have gone to me it was
like absolutely fantastic i loved it and
you as well really because you'd lived
in all them flats where you'd have to
run up and down over here with your mum
50 years on and not even a suffolk
shower can dampen dave and jean's
certainty that they made the right move
together since the early 60s they'd left
london's east end for berry at the end
of the decade
both found new jobs and more importantly
a new council house one of many which
had sprung up in and around the town
i just
moved into it quite easily it was
so easy going
um and plus the fact i had all my
friends from london come down with us we
adjusted very well yeah yeah we did just
very well yeah
and the fact is well i had my mum and
dad they moved as well and they were in
they lived in that row over there number
11. i mean they're not here now bless
them
what were your impressions of barry when
you got here as a place it was a slower
pace of life yes
a slower pace of life definitely and you
hadn't got you couldn't get on a bus and
go into the west end which when we were
caught and that was our weekend we was
always in the west end you know just get
on the bus or the tube but there's no
green and go up west you know so that's
slow wasn't it yeah it was a lot life
was a lot slower
the arrival of thousands of outsiders
like gene and dave
accelerated the transformation of berry
from a sleepy market town to the
affluent hub of today
i think the biggest
mover for bearish levels was the london
overspill coming here
in the late 1950s 60s
up till that those periods bearish and
edmunds was reliant on agriculture
with the arrival of the london overspill
we also had the associated factories the
businesses etc we had large industrial
estates built to win in the
town that was a big change so gradually
people were starting to come to terms
with modern day living
but it wasn't just barry coming to terms
with the modern world it was the entire
nation
across britain they were not just
building houses but whole new towns
motorways brought communities closer
together
and railway electrification slashed
travel times
every major city had new hospitals and
schools
but the economic boom demanded more
workers builders bus and train drivers
doctors nurses
and the new elizabethans had a ready
answer
in theory all the queen's people
belonged to one big happy imperial
family
in practice relations were strained from
the start
you know things wasn't nice at all
what we may do
or we can't go back home so we don't
have any money
you know i worked in a place and there
was this young white girl who told me to
my face that black people's brains were
small
like that
does the answer to these britishers
problems lie in britain or in the west
indies
and yet perhaps if we dig deep enough
we may find the solution hidden within
the conscience of us all
few in the empire had ever seen royalty
in the flesh but radio had carried the
queen's voice to millions now air travel
brought her to many more
so we honor the queen because when i was
about
12 the queen came to jamaica
and we lined the streets and waved
[Music]
[Applause]
as the hugh foote the governor greeted
jamaica's sovereign the airfield became
tense with eagerness with wonder
the queen once said i have to be seen to
be believed
suddenly she was able to make believers
of entire nations
well we grown up in the colonial days as
a child in jamaica
we celebrate empire day
and we all look forward to it
loyalty combined with curiosity prompted
many to take up the challenge of
rebuilding the mother country
after all what was england except
another sister island under the same
monarch and the same flag
my dad said
why does this child want to leave us
and my mom said you know she's no longer
a child you know you have to let her go
in 1954 about 10 000 west indians came
to britain
a few knew what to expect but most of
the women coming off boats in their hats
and gloves and a-line skirts expected to
set foot in the stylish royal england
that they'd seen in the newsreels
in jamaica they didn't show us snow and
things and soot you know when i came
here i said this place what what is this
place
the snow was like this and you could see
all the smoke in the skies because
people were just burning coal fire
i was surprised because you hear so much
of england the streets are paved with
gold basically but you know when you
come and you see the houses they weren't
what i expected to see
it's a big change we didn't have no
felicity no convenience
one room even when i had my first child
i was in one room
the market in brixton is for them a
happier place than a market in the
tourist paradise they have left many of
the first arrivals from the west indies
settled here in south london
over the following decade they would be
joined by others from all over the
commonwealth
many of whom found work in what is now
held to be the greatest achievement of
the elizabethan age
the first job i had was in a laundry
and the second job was with the nhs in a
maternity hospital in barnet
when i spent 12 years in that job
so my
first wages incentive hospital was 2
2.50 a week
i lived in
the nurse's home
in south london
we just stepped across to the hospitals
to look after our patients and yes it
was a very
good experience
that said it took a while for the
newcomers to grasp that some of her
majesty's subjects were a little less
equal than
others
and that here whatever the bible said
not all god's children were welcome
we were the only two black people in the
church
and they didn't take us off for
communion
and after church
everybody rebica would come and greet
everybody and merry christmas and things
and he just looked at us and passed by
the vicar
and my my my cousin started to cry so i
said forget it
let's go home i was the stronger one
even though i was a sick one
and when we went home my grandaunt said
to me millie she says how did you like
it
and i told her she said well
i wouldn't tell you it's best for you to
go and see for yourself
something new and ugly raises its head
in britain in notting hill gate only a
mile or two from london's west end
racial violence
an angry crowd of views chases a negro
into a green grocer shop while police
reinforcements are called up to check
the riot one of many that have broken
out here in a few days
[Music]
the archaic language can't hide the fact
that this was a country ill at ease with
itself
what should have been a new beginning
was starting to look like the end of an
era
what britain saw at notting hill and the
kind of hostility that ruby experienced
at this church behind me were perhaps
early signs that the new queen far from
presiding over a second golden age
was in fact in for a bumpy ride
and it soon became clear that instead of
ushering in
a new britain
she was actually seeing the collapse of
the old one her majesty queen
elizabeth's silver jubilee
25 eventful and glorious years
by the time of the silver jubilee in
1977
the crowd still turned out but the
national mood was darker a majesty fires
the fuse which will set alight the first
of a chain of jubilee beacons
the optimism of those first years was
replaced by strikes factory closures and
widespread job losses
the catastrophism preached by some both
left and right
made many wonder whether the glue that
had kept a desperate nation together
would hold much longer
racial tension on britain's streets was
just one sign of the times
and for many it had a powerful impact
by the time i hit secondary school enoch
has made the rivers of blood speech
totally polarized the playground and all
of a sudden i'm not oi let's see i'm oh
you black bastard you this you that you
know go back home this is my home
and uh it not only polarized the
playground it polarized the whole
landscape man
don letts rock star dj longtime pal and
rebel filmmaker he first made his name
telling the story of the alienated
children of the windrush generation
[Music]
no this ain't kingston jamaica this is
london in the late 70s brixton to be
precise
yes the sun was shining but the people
were feeling the pressure all the same
black and white
the social climate with mass
unemployment political turmoil the rise
of the national front and to top it off
constant grief from the police
i think what's really odd about that
stuff it's when i was growing up
13 14 15 it was normal i kind of
expected it you know if i was going to a
movie i'd always build in an extra half
an hour because i'd not get pulled up on
the way to the movie and there's times
you know i developed kind of tactics to
deal with the police like you'd be
driving along and they'd be tailing you
from behind i'd stop my car get out of
my car walk up to him like officer can i
help you and it will totally throw in
the best english i can speak english
better than these guys
across town in another britain crowds
were still flocking to that famous
palace and its familiar balcony
the pageantry of monarchy survived but
seemed increasingly detached from much
of the nation
[Applause]
don letts became the chronicler of the
challenge to tradition
for a moment anarchy found its voice
[Applause]
the sex pistols insistence that there
was no future in england's dreaming
caught the imagination
punk rock was a minority taste the
radical spirit of the times infected
even the nerdiest of young people
[Applause]
anti-racism swept me into politics it
was probably the one thing most people
could agree about and amazingly we found
an ally in an institution that most
young people thought was on its way out
when i was a student here britain seemed
that it's most angry and confrontational
and i guess i did my bit to fan the
flames as president of the student union
i organized sit-ins and demonstrations
pretty much non-stop for a year
but ironically
we i suppose you could call us the
coronation generation
found ourselves hand in hand with the
royal family on at least one thing
but britain didn't have to be a nation
divided by race
[Music]
in brixton a generation had arrived
thinking that they were already part of
a nation under one sovereign
their children grew up believing that
that nation had rejected them
one institution had the power to
reassure and to bridge the divide
and it's a responsibility embraced by
those who will wear the crown in times
to come
[Music]
june 22nd the second in line to the
throne comes to brixton to mark windrush
day
the windrush voyagers came to rebuild
britain alongside his grandmother's
generation
one day their descendants will work
alongside william and kate
they're getting to know us like asking
us about what we're doing like what
we're interested in and yeah i think
that's why it was like a really good
outside
point
it makes us feel like
these guys aren't just those people that
are
they're disconnected
we felt connected
william carried a message from her
majesty that drew a line from the past
to the future
[Music]
alongside celebrating the diverse fabric
of our families our communities and our
society as a whole
something the win rush generation has
contributed so much to
it is also important to acknowledge the
ways in which the future they sought and
deserved has yet to come to pass
we are reminded of our shared history
and the enormous contribution of the
windrush generation
without you all britain will simply not
be what it is today
[Applause]
[Music]
at the time of the coronation the future
of bolton as an industrial powerhouse
seemed secure
and a whole generation of youngsters was
destined for a career in cotton
inside the modern mill a great
transformation is taking place
a progressive industry needs progressive
workers it needs trained technicians
but the brave new world was short-lived
and within a generation
cotton was dead on its feet
you could see the hive of industry from
the hills
a pile of smoking choking smoke hung all
around
buying from abroad then came around
imported goods became the fashion and
killed the life and soul of every cotton
tone
we were about 22 though maybe
bolton bard dot thornley spent all her
working life in the mills
she now lives comfortably with her
daughter carol
but for much of their earlier lives when
the industry collapsed both mother and
daughter suffered extreme poverty
i grew up in 1984 we didn't even have an
indoor toilet we had to go through the
snow to get to the toilet and we're not
going back to the 1950s that my mum knew
of and this is 1984 when i was 16
and a lot of people live like that
like millions of working-class women
carol was destined for a series of
dead-end jobs and domestic drudgery
until one day all that changed
i was about 21 and thought my life was
over other than having babies as my dad
said i should have and then someone
suggested well why don't you look at
university
the cotton mills may have closed but the
old bolton technical college has adapted
over the years
at the beginning of the period we're
talking about the percentage of the
british population who went to
university was tiny and now it's
something that you know lots of people
now think yes that's something i can do
that opportunity has really opened up
for people over the last kind of 78
years
carol was one of those who took the
opportunity and after four years she
graduated with a degree in
education i was now a teacher
and i can't explain it's like a woman
who wants to have a child and eventually
gets pregnant when you have a burning
ambition inside you and then you
suddenly fulfill it at 26
that's what [ __ ] university did for
me it provided me with my future career
today the university has more than 11
000 students two-thirds of whom come
from bolton and the north west
it plays a crucial role in training the
next generation of nurses and paramedics
for one of the country's great post-war
success stories the national health
service
nearly 6 000 staff in the nhs
they live in bolton their families live
in bolton healthcare is one of the only
growing industries really at the moment
right so the person who's not responding
okay has he got a pulse
we work with the university to make sure
that we can have qualifications and
training places in this hospital
all right okay so i've got a pose
i'm going to check the circulation
and that's the way that we'll keep our
hospital fresh and alive and serving
this community
when the patients on this ward were born
the single biggest employer here was the
cotton industry
no one could have foreseen a world in
which medicine would replace the mill as
a lifeblood of an entire community
the queen's crimson robe is removed
in the 70 years since the coronation the
scale of change in bolton has been
unimaginable
but in all that time enthusiasm for the
queen remained
undiminished i think she's brilliant
i think
she it must be hard work doing what
she's done
the archbishop anoints her with holy oil
and consecrates her to her great office
i'm very proud of her yes i think she's
i think she's a good lady
she receives the orb
symbol of the dominion of the cross over
the world
i think the royal family are really
important but the queen by far is is the
most important person to our country
change over time is of course inevitable
but in the rural heartlands of england
where the roots of community stretch
back long before the industrial
revolution the pace of that change has
been just a little bit slower
a visitor from the berrisson edmonds of
the 1950s
would instantly recognize this place
with its quiet affluence its neat
churches its ethos of military service
there are many more people here now
there's a lot more hustle and bustle
but this town in essence remains a
microcosm of the nation that queen
elizabeth pledged to serve
all those many years ago
and the one thing that certainly hasn't
changed in berry is a shared sense of
history
a tradition of royal service and
devotion
that has stretched back for centuries
for our first prayer i'm going to invite
you all to put your hands together like
you'd see a picture of somebody praying
traditionally
[Music]
is a love that is modeled for us
by the queen
the queen who is in her own way a giant
of faith
who acts with
integrity care
and respect
for those around here
[Music]
i mean she is our history and we've held
on to that
i think she's done an absolute marvelous
job
considering all the pressure she's been
under
i mean she couldn't walk away from it
could she
no there was no way out for it she
that's that was her life
and as she said right at the beginning i
will give everything to being a queen
and yeah i think he's done a great job
most of britain has only ever known one
monarch
we had no choice like her we were born
to it
but over a tumultuous seven decades even
those who dislike the institution have
come to celebrate even to love the
person
the men and women of the windrush
generation did have a choice most
expected to return to the caribbean one
day
and there were many who would gladly
have waved them off our shores but they
stayed
i love it now because i don't know any
other life
because
i came here quite young
so i adapt myself
to the culture
of this country
i just take what i get and enjoy
i go back for holiday but my home is
still in england
[Music]
i'm glad that i came here
and this country been very very very
good to me
and i love this country and i'm not
going home and i'm not going nowhere
else
[Applause]
pretty much everybody here came to this
country from somewhere else and most
have lived through the entire
elizabethan reign
[Music]
for many this country didn't turn out to
be the place they expected
and not in a good way
but what is really striking is that
nobody have talked to regrets coming and
staying and most telling of all
when they talk about home
they're not talking about the old
country they're talking about brixton
across the span of one remarkable
lifetime
this country has been transformed
the lesson of those seven decades well
for me
that a nation securing the symbols of
continuity need to have no fear of
change in the reality
maybe the magic of this age of elizabeth
is not the past that she preserved
but the future that she has secured
and that is cause for praise
thanksgiving
and celebration
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you